welcome hello and welcome to the dark
forest my name is Jackie Kashian and I
am your host
you know the websites Jackie Kashian
calm dork Forrest calm the dark forest
calm we are on all things comedy comm
network of podcasts which have a lot of
podcasts available what else should you
don't let's do the credits Mike Rick
Burt composed and sang the song you just
heard for the dark forest with he sings
it with his girlfriend Sarah Cohen and
let me be the first to tell you they're
getting married yeah kind of exciting
anyway so Mike will sing again at the
end his words to the Mexican Hat dance
tune his lyrics Patrick Brady will fix
this audio and Vilmos fixes the website
Jackie Kashian Jackie Kashian decom has
a lot of opportunities to support the
show there is of course the amazon
banner when you order from amazon just
go to Jackie Kashian com click on the
white banner on the right hand side of
the screen that says support the show
and it'll take you to Amazon you order
like normal and I get a bit of a
kickback and I appreciate it
there is also merch there's t-shirts and
DVDs and CDs of my stand-up comedy
there's dark forest t-shirts there's
stand-ups shirts and that's all
available on the website I also have
hoodies because we're getting into that
season speaking of that season I usually
ask you to donate but it's November you
guys in November you don't donate you
don't donate to the dork forest you
donate to your local food bank and in
January I'll ask you to donate again but
this month
Google the words food bank and the name
of your town and city and you will find
people who would like you to buy them a
sandwich so there you go do that
Oh stand up wise you guys should know
that this week I'm in Tucson I'm in
Phoenix and then Tucson all this is
available on Jackie Kashian calm and
then next week
November 14th I'm doing one show in
Knoxville Tennessee at the scruffy
comedy festival so there you go let's do
the show let's get into the show hey
it's Jackie cage
welcome to the dork forest we're in the
living room in Van Nuys it's very
glamorous
I'm here with Wil Wheaton well over the
program and very happy to be here
it's a program we met I did stand-up you
did storytelling yes sketch stuff your
standup killed that night oh it killed
in front of an audience that I just
didn't think was gonna be a like into it
audience because we had the worst
heckler in the history of life yeah that
was a lot that yeah that was that was
weird cuz it was in LA in a theater yeah
the complex which I I've never met a
person who's doing theater in LA he's
like oh it's at the complex great right
I can't wait gonna drive to Santa Monica
at 4 o'clock and then after we're gonna
leave it about 5:30 and then we're going
to the complex it's really amazing right
it isn't the weirdest it is not a great
and there's nowhere to park there's
nowhere to park and also real valet
parking right and there's there's also
some kind of like um there's some weird
kind of sound that only like [ __ ]
lunatics can hear and it draws them into
an audience it's like a higher breeze
yeah and the only thing open is a liquor
store yeah like if you there's nowhere
to get coffee right I don't understand
why there's nowhere to get coffee that
that actually is offensive to me that I
mean other people want a soda other
people who want a beer yeah I need my
adult beverage of choice is coffee yeah
well they're not there they are not
going to serve your needs in any way
shape or for the wanted food you would
be screwed yeah I did actually I did
want food and I went into that that
little liquor store thing and uh some
chips they had some questionable hummus
but I was feeling you know I was know I
was feeling like I'm gonna do this oh
really yeah
did you try I did and I'm here here you
go yeah I've lived and I think I had an
apple oh no we see an apple from a
liquor store I know it's a bad idea it's
ambitious right but I'd done the hummus
you have an apple right that's true and
you needed something to dip in the end
ominous yeah I get it I get it
I'm not against all right but I have
this to say cuz sometimes it like 2:00
in the morning yeah there'll be a
pushcart lady who's making hot dogs
wrapped in bacon and I don't mind that
that's a nickel yeah
that could kill you or make you live
longer but whatever it is it's actual
food at least
it feels like an older Mexican woman has
cared about it enough whenever we leave
my wife and I have season tickets to the
Kings and whenever we leave Staples
there's always that dude who has this
kind of like weird like like janky
crafted you know streetcar thing that's
like a propane cylinder and something
that's not supposed to be a cooktop but
has become a cooktop oh yeah and it's
covered in hot dogs and bacon and onions
and it smells so good and I don't eat
hot dogs right and I know you were
tempted it was a district nine was that
the one with the shrimp people yeah yeah
it'll that's what I was watching Tripp
the district dive with my nephews in
Milwaukee and you know my nephews who
was 13 at the time said is that what la
is like and I was like kind of at a
Staples and the Staples Center and
around 1:00 in the morning that's
exactly what I was in downtown just
before I came here and and I was down
there for an appointment and I was
really hungry so I walked downtown a
little bit to let go just to a sandwich
shop good okay cause you know that and I
have not walked in downtown LA for more
than half a block ever in a decade
easily you know I don't count from the
parking lot to the Staples Center Oh
guys that see you walks yeah yes I
walked down Spring Street in and I found
this place and downtown Los Angeles is
pretty great yes block to block right oh
yeah you were on a gentrified block oh
no I was definitely a gentrified block
cuz I've been down wine and cheese shop
kind of bookstore next to it yep yep
definitely those things around and lots
of people with dogs what so many people
with dogs yeah it felt a lot like
Greenwich Village to me right right yeah
it but a one block over people live in
there well yeah like on the street
you're like oh this is actually I think
they named it Skid Row this was named
after disease yeah that place where if
you walk with if you walk with bare feet
you will get a staph infection
yes yes you will yeah it's it's I was
gonna what was I oh I had some I could
app that happens all the time
it's we have new microphones you guys so
I believe this is recording it looks
like it is but I can't the microphones
hey Patrick let's talk there's my audio
guy said oh I'll leave my Patrick little
Easter eggs in the middle of the
episodes yeah see if he's listening yeah
yes I should hope the audio guy is
listening yes yes but but I we both
clean him up and we clean them up and we
crank them out so who knows how dense we
get into it so it's at will W by the way
that's me on the Twitter yeah and then
will wheaton dotnet and willis with one
else it is and you I mean they're a
traditional year and you're a dork
luminary I think when it comes to the
dork for us we've had some some good
good dork so yeah with dork red mom you
got it you got the ancestry I think I
was just a degree I was just there
before everybody else was that's writing
it's not like I'm better at it than
anybody else or you know or or we're
like I you were going on third base for
dorks oh yeah totally
yeah I was on harmontown last night yeah
and Dan Harmon was talking about how he
came to played board games and Dungeons
& Dragons and and how the thing that
attracted him into Dungeons and Dragons
was that the imagination aspect of it
and the storytelling aspect of it and as
he's describing all this stuff he was
basically describing me yeah and my
childhood and I didn't realize that he
and I are the same age I just figured he
was older than me because he's done so
much more right and he has lived inside
of a bottle for the last 26 years so you
look great Dan Harmon but Dan Harmon
would be the first one to go oh yeah so
but it was kind of cool to hear that
like and you're Bob younger than I am
right
so there you go all right so as is aunt
Jackie I don't know I'll play Beyonce's
white aunt oh okay I don't care so but
yeah but so that was so you grew up
playing D&D yeah but unlike the set of
Star Trek because no this is
way way way before Star Trek I started I
got my first exposure to Dungeons &
Dragons around 1980 to 1983 okay and it
was with the red basic box set that TSR
had put out into like toy stores and
everything oh my great aunt got it for
me and the Christmas that I got it I was
actually really disappointed because all
my cousin's got like Nintendo Game &
Watch yeah and somebody got the the
Merlin puzzle game think I got that
Coleco football game that year
yeah the Coleco football games super and
intimidated me I was pretty good at the
Mattel electronics football one Oh but
the Coleco one was really hard because
you could pass and I minded my colony
was kind of okay but I felt like super
ripped off I was like oh this is a book
it was like where's the game yeah and
then I and and she said they say this is
a game for people who like to use their
imaginations and you've got such a great
imagination I thought you would like it
I was like whatever and then I started
reading it and and just I was I was I
fell in love instantly like heroin like
yeah like in from the get-go I was all
in before is the first book was this the
2.0 or this was in between first edition
and second edition this way so they this
rule set was was a little more
accessible than a D&D okay I had fewer
charts and it didn't have to hit armor
class zero and it was more just sort of
like roll d20 apply a modifier and then
if you hit these you know yeah fighters
do d12 damage clerics tend to doodie
tend and stuff like that yeah okay cuz I
played three point five yes and I play
Pathfinder and I play and I play all of
them because Andy Ashcraft has done what
you have done I think he got into a D&D
or whatever yeah a D&D actually sounds
like something that they would give
children a medic use medicine for now
yeah and but the but he's been playing
forever and my cuz the door for started
and I've always been a video game there
but I was never a board game or or
tabletop game pen-and-paper stuff
I met him because I didn't know what it
was right now cuz Dungeons & Dragons
I got it mixed up with LARPing right
which I also didn't do and I thought
that you'd address up and go to the
woods so you sort of came to the whole
role-playing experience fairly like
relatively relatively recently compared
to you know in the 80s because LARPing
did it exist way well actually back then
the only LARPing really was like society
for creative anachronism right which was
which was terrifying and and and remains
intense yeah and and events somebody on
SCA I mean my buddy Lee is in SCA yeah
but he has actually left it for like a
decade
yeah then gone back to it cuz he's like
I need a break from you
enormous Lee committed humans I know I
kind of want to learn how to do like
soft sword combat okay so like Beaufort
now and yeah like proper combat yeah now
there's two kinds of luck because Andy
has always LARP like the early 80s it
was more theater LARP it was before LARP
was a real thing I guess and he's got
somebody of his who's who runs starship
Valkyrie and it's once a month either
you pay 20 bucks and you get to be part
of a crew on a starship and and I was
the doctor one time very exciting yeah
and I usually do craft services yeah
Andy's run three Sandman larks with 40
people at one man and for me it was I
was the first the Sam band awake was the
I've had four reels goosebumps thinking
about that right it is cool me and Maria
Bamford did craft services for AHA so
cool so they we got to play like sort of
NPCs and that would give us small parts
yeah and and Maria actually they still
talk about it because everybody had they
didn't know who was gonna die it wasn't
necessarily gonna be dream yeah so they
wrote everybody wrote different people
were one-act tiny when I plays of the
death of each of the different endless
right yeah so Maria played the death of
desire so she
laid apathy and they talk about
Bamford's performance of apathy because
I would have thought of it when you said
Maria Bamford I thought she'd be such a
great delirium oh she would be great
delirium or death or uh yeah yeah she
but she played apathy to my buddy our
friend Jim Keller's uh desire yeah and
that was his death that's incredible
right yeah and then and we had but there
were theater more like the one that we
had here at the house for about a year
once every couple of months was a
Deadwood LARP yeah and that I bet a lot
of [ __ ] in that right what a
[ __ ] a lot of the n-word yeah I
was like you're gonna need to move your
your Union soldier bar into my garage
because we have neighbors and I know
that in character right but keep it to
[ __ ] other together yeah right now
we're trying to build a coalition you
know I really wanted to like Deadwood
and I could not get Pat like I couldn't
get past a language not because I'm
prude but because it just it it felt
Larry or the curse all the cursing like
every fifth word being [ __ ] felt
so it just kept pulling me out
it just kept yanking me out of the story
and I couldn't commit to it and at that
time I'm like at that time I'm watching
the wire for the first time and I'm
watching Sons of Anarchy for the first
time and I'm watching it's not when I'm
watching Breaking Bad and it's like well
you know I'm running out of
discretionary time but I feel like it's
one of those things that like I feel
like I've I've made a bad choice but you
know the great thing about it's out
there right and I was never able to and
he loved it start to finish I thought it
was a little dark I mean yeah like
Breaking Bad
I have Rangers of the dark force know
this about me I watched the first season
of The Wire and I was like this isn't
gonna end well
yeah good breaking bread third three
seasons and then when what's-his-face
got a girlfriend I was like oh it's good
all work out then what's this phases
girlfriend gets killed and I'm like oh
we're done now yeah so I don't it's not
I don't need to watch Super Friends
right just but there have
to peace redemption of a giant fan of it
could be dark yeah but there has to be
like I've never seen The Godfather - I
saw the father really they are amazing
there I know that they're well done I
know they're well written I know they're
me I would read I've and I've said this
before I would rather live through
Godfather - yeah then watch Godfather
it's just it drives me nuts when the bad
decisions are being made yeah I'm like
oh my god food lateral steps and this
wouldn't happen has anyone presented to
you this idea okay yes please for in
Breaking Bad okay Walter White is not
the hero right like he is he's the
villain he's absolutely the villain he's
a POV character but he's the villain
Jesse Pinkman is the character who is
the hero who is the hero who needs who
needs and eventually gets Redemption
does he know I forget then guys if
there's going to be a spoiler moment
something that's been available for five
years so get over it I been told about
the last episode yeah and I tried to get
back into it when the because everyone
was like it's amazing and get back into
it but it was hard but the last so I
know that Walter may or may not die
isn't it right isn't it unclear well so
there's a couple there's a yeah Jesse
gets out okay and there's there's a
couple of there's a couple of theories
that are actually very interesting to me
the one that I that I really liked that
Vince Gilligan has said is actually not
right is that the penultimate episode is
actually how it ends the last episode
like the series ends with with Walt
being he's like in a bar right and and
we know that he's dying we know that
he's got cancer we are they saying he's
in a bar and he ready has realized that
everything that he liked kind of all the
justifications he made for like why he
was doing this they're all [ __ ] and
he wasn't doing this stuff because he
loves his family like that was a
convenient reason like he loved the
power and he loved being good at
something and he loved people being
afraid of him he loved feeling like him
powered by all that and he he so he does
and this in the second to last episode
which i think is called
giman dias which i think is the perfect
title for the episode he goes to this
bar okay and he's like making his
decision like what's he gonna do and
like where is he gonna go and the last
shot of that episode is his whiskey
glass with a napkin on it like maybe
he's coming back for the whiskey but
he's just not there anymore right right
and then and then he's and then he's
gone and and at the begin and and that
is I think a fantastic place to end that
actually loved the ending of The
Sopranos I really like I really liked
that it puts me as an audience member in
the emotional place of the of the the
POV character which is I don't know
what's gonna happen next
you know I will live the rest of my life
like at the end of the Sopranos they
will live the rest of their lives
wondering if that guy walking into the
bathrooms coming out with a gun yeah is
that person in the car next to me gonna
shoot me yeah is my car gonna blow up
when I turn it on that's the rest of
their lives right and I liked that as an
audience member
yeah I was left having absolutely no
idea what happened and everything like
it could have been great or it could
have been terrible that was I loved that
I didn't I did not feel that it was a
cop-out
now I don't I don't think it's kept but
i think that it's a it's a it's a
conscious choice that i respect but did
you ever read a short story from the
1800s called the lady or the tiger no oh
my god
that is exactly what that is it's about
it's a love it's a couple in love yeah
she's the daughter of the king he is I'm
paraphrasing anyone yelling at their
iPod so and and he's just a peasant or
whatever she falls in love the King says
well you can't have them and she's like
but our it'll kill me not to have him I
love him so much he's like oh yeah do
you love them so then they're in an
arena and he says how much do you love
them behind one of those doors is
another woman he can live out his life
in love with that woman for the rest of
his life the other one is a tiger that
will maul him and kill him tell him
which one to open
she does and he goes to the door she
picked for it mm-hmm that's the end of
the story yeah which one did she love
him enough to let him go to another
woman or did she love him so much no one
else could have him and she had it I
love that and I love that empowers me as
the reader to make that decision right
if presuming that so I always pick the
lady III think that better that are
Wheatley do you pick the lady or the
tiger though without knowing without
knowing their whole story I can't I
can't say but that's what's so cool
about it right the I tell people when
when we're playing games never give up
the joy of playing the game in pursuit
of winning the game never sacrifice the
journey to get to the destination right
that is that I never played tabletop
games until I met Andy right yeah so
when he was like oh we're gonna go have
a board game night I was like I'm the
youngest of six yeah and I said I hate
board games I come with the power of the
Sun and he said that's because you play
sibling rules yeah where if you don't
forget if you forget to do something you
don't get to do it with my friends I've
been playing with them for over 20 years
yeah we have weeded that guy out yes
that's the same in my group right he's
like everyone wants to win but no one
cares if they win yeah so they just want
everyone to have a good time and to play
and they have fun playing the game so
and not long ago one of one of his best
friends
Judy Phil Adler their son Bernard was
five years old and I they were playing a
game and I sat down to play Candyland
uh-huh so Judy comes over and says how's
it going and I said he's winning he's
winning and I'm not letting him win or
anything and he was five and Jim please
please do not let him win he's gonna be
playing games for the next 70 years he's
gonna learn how to live it's not gonna
kill him yeah let's go play this game at
least a hundred more time yeah yeah it
was like that makes so much more sense
yeah because I would rather yeah I would
I would play games with you because I
can't if someone gets like if they're
it's men men maxing their character
drives me crazy right all those terms
that I never drives me nuts completely
misses the point of why you're doing it
yeah what's described playing in a
fantasy world and play a cool game yeah
I it is just as satisfying for me
to be really like to to lose a good game
as it is to win a good because they feel
like well look I brought my best right
and and your best was was better than my
best okay maybe next time my best to be
better than your best right but as that
relates to that story
yeah that story's not about the ending
that story is about the journey of it
and and I I like that I mean when I was
his life part of it or just watching
that person lived their lives but the
story of the lady in the tiger is very
much about her having to make that
decision and and getting into the her
psychology and and and what why does she
love him so much and what way does she
love him and I how and without he should
and and by letting the reader make the
decision for which door is opened I
actually really like that yeah I have
never felt like things need to be all
wrapped up it drives me crazy when
something falls apart in the third act
when they bail on the promise of the
premise or they just get you know they
get when they don't know what you know
or they don't know where they're going
or they go oh no we have to end this
right right that drives me nuts that is
hard and actually without the second to
last episode of Breaking Bad I would
have been really disappointed in the
last episode so there's a theory that
Walt actually dies
yeah and the last episode it takes place
within the like those like few moments
of of his of his life slipping away yeah
as because basically everything he ever
wanted happens in the last episode he
sets up his family he gets back at the
people who he feels have wronged him he
sets Pinkman free and then and then he
dies before the police can arrest him
and in the script that says the police
come in but Walt but but he's but but
but Walt is dead Heisenberg got away
it's a beautifully written ending right
yeah but it I would have felt like oh my
god it's such fanservice again it's
exactly everything everything worked out
well it should not work out well for him
he's the villain right so without and I
and I I know that Vincent said that's
the end and that's great you know and
and and I think it's really cool that
there are two equally satisfying endings
that we can kind of do that I that I
think that we can choose from and I I
like art that does that I like art that
challenges me and and like and that
involves me I don't want something that
holds my hand and and just kind of walks
me through everything I write I want to
work for it a little bit I I believe
that everything worth doing is hard okay
and and that can even be like getting
through a museum and like appreciating
the stuff that's there like right
figuring out like what's that about you
know like I like that yeah yeah that's
uh that I don't know I I will think
about that because I know that for me
like to watch the wire and to watch
Breaking Bad to see even like Sons of
Anarchy and stuff you're like okay I I
know those dirtbags yeah I don't want to
hang out with them in my free time sure
and I always want like whenever I go
back to my hometown which I love I love
south wall here Wisconsin everybody's
but some people didn't get out and
you're I just look at him and I'm like
seriously you could just leave there's
no you can go get a job shoveling sand
in any stupid town in the world right
and I think they're so weird about that
it's sad right it's sort of like like
didn't you want something more but then
at the same time maybe they didn't and
they're fine with it right and she lives
across the hall from her mom her mom and
they get high together and they have you
know what they have an interest maybe
she finally has the relationship with
her mom that she always wanted that she
know that she could never have and maybe
I edit out her last name maybe not great
but okay so this has been fascinating
this is a great rabbit hole but I kind
of wanted to talk because I don't know
anybody who brews beer I know people who
have hobbly like as a hobby hobbly has
have brewed some beer oh and then called
it a day
yeah but you you got into it and you're
you actually have a kit right don't you
have a kit that you're willing to say go
for this yeah yeah for the last couple
of years I worked with Northern Brewer
there
an online home brewing supply and I
designed recipes and
while the stocks while the stock lasts
you know there's there's now a fight
they're not making them anymore as a
finite number of them left Oh while
these but while the stock lasts someone
who wants to make I there's there's two
that are up that are up right now
there's a there's a kind of a double IPA
it's about a eight and a half percent
IPA that has a lot of Crystal caramel
malt in it so it has some sweetness to
balance out the the hop bitterness and
that's called vandalised PA okay
named in honor of my wife who puts a
googly eyes on everything excellent and
then there's another one called wood
stout which is a beer that I made with
the Stone Brewing Company with with Greg
cook and drew Curtis from FARC who drew
is also a candidate for governor and
Kentucky right now okay and that is an
imperial russian stout brewed with
pecans and chocolate liqueur and quarter
aged in bourbon barrels used bourbon
girls and if you don't know how to brew
beer can you buy that kitten it's super
easy there's yet super easy there's that
there's a recipe sheet that you just
follow and you are given sort of the
ingredients to yeah they all come in
they all come in like a box and you can
do it not just with mine I mean if you
just want to do like let's say yeah you
want to make see you like the Sierra
Nevada Pale Ale okay um and you just
want to make kind of like a West Coast
style Pale Ale okay that's like let's
see that's of a small a specialty mall
probably two kinds of hops and five
ingredients plus water okay and and it's
just a matter of like following a recipe
and putting them together the right way
and and you're okay so what we're do you
you have to okay let's start let's
pretend I don't know anything about
brewing beer okay out okay uh all I know
is that yeast is involved yeah and that
in water yeah that's it okay what are
the other ingredients alright what
happened okay so here's how you turn
basically making beer is the process of
turning grain and water into a fermented
beverage okay
okay barley is used to as your primary
ingredient so what you're doing is
you're looking for sugar that can be
ferment
right and the sugar feeds the yeast you
get that sugar out of malted barley and
okay so you can take regular barley and
mend it you could it's a lot easier to
go to a store and buy I'm sorry
yeah because what they do is barley is
put into a kiln and then depending on
the heat of the kiln and the time of the
barley in the kiln the barley itself
changes the lower the temperature and
the less time it's in there the lighter
the barley is think of it like putting
toast in a toaster okay right and then
so if you put toast in a toaster and you
don't leave it in for very long it's
just gonna make it kind of crunchy it's
not going to affect the flavor of the
bread very much but if you leave it in
there for a long time up until it gets
burned then it's gonna very very very
differently change the flavor of it
that's how killing barley works okay to
Malta and when they kill MIT to malted
is it just barley and water
it's just barley that goes into it it's
not even you know the water comes the
water comes into the brewing process so
then what you do is you get all that
grain yeah right you you get the amount
of grain that you want to use and that
varies from beer style to beer style and
there's different kinds of different
levels of melting of the barley that you
use right and that's that's
unnecessarily technical doesn't matter
all you need to know is that you you get
a bunch of grain together okay rush it
yeah then you take all that crushed
grain and you put it into something like
a big in in brewing like a big pot or a
big bucket or a cooler or something like
that
then you add water hot water and
depending on the temperature of the
water different chains of sugar
molecules will be extracted from the
malted barley okay if the water is on
the cool side sugar where the molecule
chains are very long will come out that
sugar cannot be eaten by the yeast it's
called unfermented sugar that's what
gives beer sweetness and body okay right
then as the temperature gets a little
bit higher the beer and the molecules
get shorter and the yeast can actually
eat those molecules and bite them off
the chain and and then they can ferment
them and that is called fermentable
sugar okay then so what you do
is you you take that that grain and that
water you mix it all up and then you let
it sit for a certain amount of time and
that varies from beer to beer usually
it's about an hour sometimes it's a
little bit more okay all right let me so
you have a malted barley mm-hmm you
crush it yep you add water and depending
on the heat of the water you create
essentially a fermented liquid from a
fermentable liquid a fermented Bullock
with you have the fermentation doesn't
happen until you put the Easton and that
comes a little bit later okay because
now you're just water and barley right
so now what you basically have is a very
sweet sugary liquid flavored liquid okay
not it uh and it kind of it kind of
tastes like the water in oatmeal I guess
right and and then you and then you
collect all that that liquid you grain
very draining yeah and and and then you
you collect it and and there's a couple
of other steps that are important but
you collect if you collect all that
liquid and then that liquid goes into a
kettle that's going to be boiled okay
okay then you start you turn on the heat
mm-hm and the water eventually heats up
and it starts to boil okay then when it
starts to boil what you're doing by
boiling it is you're killing any
bacteria that might be in there okay and
you're also reducing the the volume by
boiling it off and that's really
important because as the liquid boils
off the sugar remains right so just like
any sauce you're just making it slightly
more dense and more sugar in the liquid
the more potential alcohol in the final
beer okay that and in brewing we call
that the the gravity of the of the beer
okay so what usually however long it
takes most boils run about an hour okay
for certain like beers that have higher
gravity like our wood stout is closer to
90 minutes sometimes 120 minutes it just
depends depends on a few factors like
humidity and alpha exactly so what you
do in this process now is you start the
water boiling and then you add hops hops
are a flower
that is that they grow on a vine and
hops have antibacterial properties in
them and they have antimicrobial
properties in them and they have like
these little oil glands that have
bitterness in them hops is what makes
beer bitter is it a grain no it's a
flower it's a flower
yes sir a flower hops our flower they
grow into growing little cones
okay Brewer once pointed out to me that
hops are in the same phylum as marijuana
okay so they have the same idea that the
same fundamental without the
psychoactive compounds the same
fundamental like bits of oil and and the
same kind of like soap errific effect
that there's there's a similarity in
them so and what do you grow have they
always grown in the what hops is a kind
of flower yeah hops ism's long hops is a
vine it's a vine uh-huh and they grow
all over the place and depending on
where in the world they grow they get
different characteristics right so a
hops that grow in America typically in
the Pacific Northwest tend to have like
us an aroma that's kind of like pine
needles a little bit like pine trees
like bees and different kinds of honey
yeah sort of yeah okay but it just so
there's different kinds of hops but
they're all hops yeah and then the
different hops come from they come from
depending it depends on things like soil
and climate and and things like that
hops that are grown in Europe typically
in Germany Bavaria Czechoslovakia those
hops sir tend to be very neutral they
don't have a lot of flavor to them if
anything their flavor might be a little
grassy okay but it's very very very mild
those are called noble hops because they
don't have like a lot of intense flavor
okay so they're not going to affect what
you're doing with the rest of your
ingredient right and that and that's
because traditional beer making styles
in in that part of the world tended to
put the flavour emphasis on the east
rather than on the hops
how much hops do you put into the in a
five gallon batch of home brewed beer a
typical like Pale Ale probably has like
between one and a half and three ounces
of hops in it and an IPA probably has
between three and five it just depends
okay so it happens is you start boiling
your your your well your liquid and you
put you put hops in right yeah the first
hops those are called additions the
first hops addition you make imparts a
great deal of bitterness to the beer
because while it's boiling the oils that
are in the hop flower they isomerize and
they kind of like start to bind
themselves to what's in the water but
the boiling allows some of the like
flavor and aroma to boil off leaving
behind this thing called an alpha acid
which is what gives hops their
bitterness different types of hops have
different levels of alpha acids in them
so for example hop like the Simcoe
variety has a lot of Alpha acids in it
so it can be very bitter but then a hop
like I don't know like check sauce has
significantly less it's not it's not
going to be nearly as bitter and then
you put in those hops additions at
different stages the first hops addition
you make is going to make your hot is
going to add bitterness to your beer and
then the second hop addition you make
because that's a little bit later it's a
bit a little bit closer to when you
finish the boil that hops addition is
going to add some hop flavor so that's
where the the region that your hops come
from starts to really matter because if
you want a citrusy beer yeah the
Deschutes fresh squeezed beer which has
a real citrus flavor to it then you
would probably want to put in some hops
that are from America or New Zealand or
something like that and then the very
last hops addition you make is your
aroma addition and aroma is a huge
component of taste right ok yeah because
that goes in last it boils off the least
so it sort of steeps in in the in the
beer this is called Wirt now the bureau
okay and and then you finish your boil
you turn it off right turn the thing off
then you want to cool that liquid from
boiling to room temperature as fast as
you can and what you do is you you get
sort of meat you make a whirlpool in
your beer right spin you sort of spin it
all around right yeah and then the hot
the pieces of hops that are in your beer
the little bits of grain that are left
over they all sort of gather up in the
middle of it right and then they kind of
just sit there and then you gently after
its cooled down right to around 80
degrees okay gently drain it into a like
home brews use buckets okay or like
glass carboys like you know from like a
sparkle it's sort of situation at that
shape whatever and then you when all
that is done you like stir it up with a
spoon or you or you a you add oxygen to
it because boiling like you had a bunch
of oxygen back into it and in one of a
number of different ways and then you
put yeast in and yeast comes either in
vials or in little packets it just
depends there's different styles yes no
no beer you steer yeah you don't use
bread yeast I mean you could but it
wouldn't it would not be nearly as
viable and it wouldn't taste as good
okay
because different strains of yeast do
different types of flavor okay and this
is one of the most fascinating things
about beer making for me is that I could
use the exact same grains the exact same
hops and two different kinds of yeast
and I'm gonna get beer that Haste's to
massively different ways yeah because
what happens is the yeast go the yeast
of these like single-celled organisms
and you dump about a billion cells into
a into a right but they're microscopic
right yeah I mean yeah I mean it's it's
about the size of like maybe
one-and-a-half sweet'n low packets okay
and you dump it in and then they sort of
like they've they're dormant right but
right cells kind of wake up and the
cells let go all right sugar let's have
a party and they start eating that sugar
they absorb the sugar and then they bud
new cells yeah and while that goes they
absorb that they eat the sugar
then they their waste is carbon dioxide
and ethyl alcohol and those two things
are given off through the the budding
and yes s of the East and it takes
anywhere from four to ten days depending
on what style you're making and the East
they just keep doing this over and over
and over again and they replicate
themselves over and over and over again
until a point where they basically
they've created so much alcohol that
they get drunk and go to sleep
mao and that's called flock that's
called flocculation they all fall down
to the bottom and once that happens as a
brewer you then collect that fermented
liquid which is now beer yeah and you
put it into bottles yeah or you put it
into a keg okay you you you mix in a
little bit of corn sugar to wake up the
type like the tiny little bit of yeast
that's still kind of in the liquid from
imported in the yeast will sort of a
little bit will eat that a little bit
then it carbonates it in the bottle or
in the keg oh and and then probably i
was going to ask about the carbonation
yes okay so wait so you've now made a
kettle of beer mm-hmm you've made a
kettle of beer and now you put in the
yeast and it you pour it into a your
it's in a bucket now right that's and
then you seal up the bucket anyway days
mostly yeah you put a thing called a
called a an airlock which is a two piece
plastic thing that has like a tube that
comes up and then there's a little
plastic hat that sits on top of it and
you fill it up with purified water or
some people use a high proof vodka or
something like that okay what happens
and then there's a lid on top of that
whole device and what happens is carbon
dioxide can bubble out through that but
nothing can go back in that's the way
that the little hat falls down on the on
the top of the it's like a valve to sort
of lead off like it's sort of like a
one-way yeah yeah that's that's a much
more succinct way of describing it it's
saying yeah so it's like a one-way valve
that opens that lets the carbon dioxide
escape so it doesn't blow up right
alright and I think that's a problem
when you put it in the bottles too is
sometimes it is yeah very rarely but
sometimes and then there's some there's
a thing called fermenting under pressure
where you put where your fermentation
happens in a vessel that can
actually endure that kind of pressure so
the beer is actually carbonating itself
while it's fermenting that's what a lot
of commercial Brewers do because a real
swore does okay it's sort of like
reduces the amount of time that that has
to elapse between the beginning of
fermentation and the packaging of the
beer okay yeah once you've started
anywhere from three to five weeks mm-hmm
you've got beer that you made and then
once you've made that one beer like
because it sounded like you could mix
different Barley's oh and is that is
because what we what we have just gone
through yeah we have made one kind of
beer right and it's a very basic sort of
Pale Ale right yeah okay so if you
wanted to do use two different kinds of
barley and and then would you would you
mix them in before the wait when the
yeast was gonna happen no you would do
that before you soak them in water
that's called the mash also so for
example if I open to different Barley's
yeah you put them all - you put all them
all together at the same time if I'm
gonna make a pale ale it's gonna be
mostly just like two-row barley and
probably like maybe some crystal 20 malt
or something like that which is sort of
like a very lightly toasted caramely
kind of malt that just gives it a little
bit of color and a little bit of flavor
okay if I'm gonna make stout or a porter
then I'm going to use Shiro barley a lot
of two-row barley as my as my base malt
but then I'm going to add Pro I'm going
to add definitely gonna add like some
patent malt which is almost like almost
a burnt black kind of malt I might add
some chocolate malt which isn't
chocolate it's just that chocolate
refers to the color not okay ever I
might even add like some caramel 90 or
some caramel 120 or something like that
these are all barley malts that look
like those things yeah and so and are
they different Barley's grown different
places I don't know I don't know
precisely where they're growing I mean I
it's it's it's it is generally all two
row
barley and it is the the different
colors of it and the different like
flavor profiles of it right are really
dependent upon how its malted okay then
there's also there's there's a few other
things too you can use rye you can use
wheat writers there's some malt that can
be smoked whatsoever that it gets you
can use like a smoked malt that kind of
is you know gives it that smoky flavor
that's how stone makes their smoked
porter okay you cannot make a gluten
free beer normally unless you use like
rice or sorghum and it's awful and it
just tastes terrible yeah my my little
sister has celiac disease so she can't
drink beer but she so she sometimes
drinks this like rice beer and I just
think it's gross like it's awful like
that's that's not good now is is why
naturally gluten-free is the booze of
choice for the gluten usually like
whiskey's work or Siders wait it doesn't
whiskey have grain in it or is that I'm
thinking of grain alcohol and yeah it
does but something about the process of
it I guess is different I not can free
it up yeah tequila vodka rum you know
there's anything that's derived from
fruits or other starches or something
okay but there is at the moment there is
a there's an enzyme that a company
called white labs releases and white
labs primarily grows yeast and and I buy
a lot of my yeast from them but they
have a clarifying agent that so this is
the thing that you put into your
fermenter and what it does is it's a
bunch of proteins and the proteins
attach themselves to molecules that are
left over in the beer after you've
you've brewed it while it's fermenting
alright and it makes it heavier than
everything that's in the beer and it all
falls down to the bottom of the tank and
you just pull it out and it's not there
anymore but that was originally
developed to make the beer look clearer
so it looked pretty so it pulls out
proteins and things like that and it
wants to because you want your pails and
your lagers and things you want to be
able to see through them you don't want
them to look like chunky you know how do
you yeah yeah
right and and if it does look like it
doesn't matter it doesn't change the
flavor right like that it's just sort of
like a visually unappealing right but
some they were running some tests on it
and they found that this particular
clarifying agent also bound to the
gluten molecules that were left in the
beer word right and they did some tests
and the amount of gluten is expressed in
parts per billion was less in beer made
with barley oh that was treated with
this like totally natural enzyme okay
then in the beers that are specifically
like made to not have any gluten at all
right like this okay from Y source or
whatever like that stone sells if you're
called delicious IPA that is there by
law they have to call it gluten reduced
okay um there's probably still trace
minerals there's a little bit I mean
yeah but there's there's always gonna be
a little bit but it's even less than in
specifically gluten-free beers so anyone
listening to this who has celiac disease
should talk to their doctor but they
should definitely talk to their doctor
and definitely you know like don't don't
take my word for it yeah but anecdotally
I do have friends who have celiac
disease who drink stones delicious IPA
which I love by the way it's a
magnificent IPA and they don't and they
don't have any trouble at all okay yeah
that actually that disclaimer that goes
with everything man if if I have told
you to watch a movie see your doctor go
talk to your doctor I cannot be held
responsible for the fact that you saw
Ant Man and didn't wreck it because
you're made of stone
ask your doctor of watching daredevil on
Netflix is right for you exactly it's
watching the second season of Heroes may
lead to irrational anger and feelings of
betrayal if you're age less for four
episodes or longer please please talk to
your doctor did you have problems with
lost
I understand people had problems with
lost yeah after doctor lost was the show
that that taught me that it was okay to
break up with bad TV oh there you go I
have a whole piece in my stand-up set
about how you break up with bad TV okay
so I'd like listen it's not it's not
them it's you
you know it's not it's not it's fault
right you had you had a great season
together it was amazing but it's just
it's really time for you to go see other
people I have to tell you that I had the
hardest I can't remember the first book
that I was like no no I'm not finishing
you I don't have to know I don't need to
know how it works out because this is so
poorly written you know the math problem
that I figured out for me was fifty page
no sorry yeah fifty no fifty to a
hundred pages or one hour whichever
comes first
okay I'll give a book that there are a
couple of authors get extra time for me
just because I know their style Dan
Simmons gets more than that no no that's
Dan Brown dancin Dan Simmons wrote
Hyperion and the terror the Shrike yeah
first my period I was like oh this is a
good ad well I gotta go as a father that
story just wrecked me I bet and so he
gets a little longer Neal Stephenson
gets a little longer but but they're
guys that I love and trust so well yes
you know if they're taking their time I
know but they earned that overtime
weight and that that is the thing it's a
that's kage Baker gets that with me
which is she wrote science fiction the
company series yeah and there's only
there's a finite number of books cuz she
passed away but there's one book that
was uh it was a fantasy book and they're
out of they were written out of order
weirdly enough just oh there's a weird
choice yeah and so I read the second one
first and I was like what is this world
yeah and then I read the the first the
first one she wrote I read that one
first and then the second one she wrote
which was explained the world
I read that second I was like now I need
to read the first one again so that I
know what the hell happened I read
prelude to foundation after I read
foundation and I really didn't like
prelude to foundation and I just like
this could have started with foundation
Italy you yeah right the first time
yeah you were correct you were really
okay yeah did not need this you did not
need a a prequel to this that always
feels it always feels like a publisher
choice quite honestly where you're like
keep writing right I think it was Anne
McCaffrey yeah if your characters are
dying of old age yeah
same with lois mcmaster bujold like you
don't have to kill the Harper Harper
lives forever for me and so but I don't
know they might do it to JK Rowling as
well yeah like I love Harry Potter so
much I love those books I wish those
books had existed when I was a little
boy because the fundamental message of
the first few books of that series are
like hey are you a weird person who
doesn't fit in anywhere do people make
fun of you because of who you are do you
try real hard to fit in and you still
can't guess what there's a place where
what makes you weird here actually makes
you awesome and everybody's gonna love
that and you're gonna meet other people
like you and you're gonna belong oh my
god I needed that so badly when I was a
little kid and I never I never got it
right until you were an adult and you
found your people yeah and that's I mean
that's that is true except for that I
will say this is the kid that I babysat
H to child care when I first moved to
Los Angeles I was one of my day jobs
yeah and the kid that I babysat for
turned 11 and she had she was then the
Harry Potter books were still coming out
and so I think we were on like the
fourth or fifth book at graveyard game
fifth one and she turns 11 and she sobs
uncontrollably that there's no letter
for aa and I was like I get it you think
you think be a muggle and you're like I
get it wants to be a muggle and you're
not it's not that it's exactly what you
said it is which is eventually you will
find your weirdos and you will have a
community and it'll be great and now
she's a perfectly nice well-adjusted 26
year old who has plenty of plenty of
friends I was at I was at a convention
and someone said this was misdelivered I
think it's for you and they gave me a
Hogwarts letter and I and I I burst into
tears because I was so excited that is
because I couldn't I couldn't believe it
like there it was yeah
see my monster book of monsters that's
great if you pull this tongue he makes a
noise and that's my wand on this I know
and then I have all the British ones in
hardcover but I also have the British
ones in paperback if you want to borrow
them people and then give them back to
me my friend Kaley Cuoco who I work on
the Big Bang Theory with yeah she loves
Harry Potter and I'm really proud to be
the person who introduced her to Harry
Potter I introduced Chris Hardwick to
Harry Potter oh that's great I was so
yes so she hundred percent I just
wrapped a show that'll air in about
three weeks from now and probably
November so yeah so this will be on some
I think my episode will be on before the
end of November oh cool
and she was so we were on the set and I
said hey have you been a Harry Potter
world yet and she goes what do you mean
you have been a Harry Potter world and I
say you know Harry Potter she said it's
it's the most amazing thing and I said
did you go and did you get a wand she
goes yeah you can go to the shop and a
wand will choose you you know Alexandra
yeah Alexandra she'd worked out many
episodes ago yeah about Harry Potter
world Alexander's my assistant for
people who are coming to this who don't
listen to Jack podcast but if like
seeing me talk about this yeah so yeah
yeah Alex a [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah Alex
loves Harry Potter as much as I do
and she was great she was a she was in
the right there's a safe space
yeah chose correctly yeah my family
there's four of us in my family yeah and
all four Hogwarts houses are represented
interesting what do you what do you
we've all been properly sorted by the
sorting hat that's right
so I am Ravenclaw my my son Nolan is
Slytherin my son Ryan is Gryffindor
which is amazing because Ryan and Harry
Potter have the exact same birth date
July 31st 1989 exact same breath oh wow
yeah and and my wife Hannah's Hufflepuff
okay meet yeah it's really great so I
have four banners hanging in my game
room did you do that at Potter
mutter mutter more Dada more Dom that's
where the real sorting has the real sort
of guy I feel like I did it but I can't
remember
Wow I sleep I drain them fill away I
sleep in ravenclaw pajamas that is
adorable and and I wear ravenclaw eyes
as often as I can
oh that is great that is by the way it's
I'm talking to Wil Wheaton by the way
Wil Wheaton dotnet and at will W and you
know what I have never listed two but
I've wanted to listen to because I read
it and that I had him on the dork force
was Ernie Cline ready Oh
Ernie's awesome he brought his DeLorean
it was a live episode in Boston yeah
yeah and and I read it is I describe it
to people as this is not complete this
is not it but it is an effective way to
get people to read it yeah which is it's
a hunger game for 40 year old darts
that's super true it's yeah it's there's
no reason not to not to dive in it's a
it it reads quickly it is a wonderful
book and it has a amazing heart and good
action I did the audiobook and you did
the audiobook which is what everyone
always tells me had you read it before
no I didn't I asked Ernie do I need to
read this before and he's like well you
know I think you should and I said I
just I feel like I'm so familiar with I
know this character so well and I'm so I
read the first few chapters okay I am
like I get this and I thought I think
there needs to be a point of view a
sense of wonder that comes out of Wade
as this stuff is happening yeah and I
feel like because he's so constantly
surprised by so many awesome things oh
my god said I said I said I feel that as
an actor I mean I could I could act that
sure or I could genuinely experience it
happen yeah and it was a risky choice
but it but it paid off well you can
always do another take it's like you
read it and you're like what the hell
just happened and and then you could I
mean if it hadn't worked but it but you
can only get that surprised once yeah so
that's an inch that's a fascinating
choice Ernie is a great spoken word
record of stamp of slam poetry yeah
ultraman is Airwolf which is actually
how I discovered him yeah I
I heard him do a thing about how you
know the 80s were what it was like when
he was a kid and I submitted it to FARC
in like 2002 or something like that yeah
and it blew up yeah and it kind of like
elevated Ernie's visibility right to a
point where lay people that's what you
are yeah I mean I I want to use your
powers for good I do I feel like I have
a limited amount of time and I have a
limit I have a limited amount of time to
like do something with my life and I
have a limited amount of time where
people are going to pay attention to
whatever comes out of my mouth right I
feel like there's you know I'm not going
to solve the climate crisis by myself
I'm not gonna solve the violence crisis
by myself I'm not gonna like magically
make people tolerant by myself but I can
over time maybe just spread a little bit
more awesome stuff in the world try to
try to do something good with what I've
been given
yeah yeah well that's nothing wrong with
any of that's awesome yeah the pop
screens on this thing I just I just
added a pop filter to my setup at home
or for my podcast I do two podcasts to
do a podcast called radio free burrito
right which lives at Radio Free burrito
calm yep and I do a podcast with my
friend Mikey Newman called TV crimes a
podcast of [ __ ] a podcast of cinematic
justice okay and so so yeah I couldn't
vlog line was but so TV crimes is a
thing that Mike Anna do we watch TV
shows from like the 70s to about the 90s
okay and then we recap them yeah and
then we put them on trial for whatever
their crime was and we make and we
pitched the crime to each other right we
pitched the charges to each other and
then whoever is not pitching as the
judge and jury okay and we decide you
know we declare what it's like what it's
sentence is going to be so what shows
have you done Thunder in paradise
it's a it's a under in paradise is a
Hulk Hogan series that started out as a
made-for-tv movie where
he is like an ex-special forces person
who has a Knight Rider boat and and in
fact my friend Matt Fraction calls it
Knight boat and his yeah and it's it's
really like it's it's it's bad like it's
really really bad you try to grab
something that isn't necessarily oh we
look for stuff that's terrible okay yeah
and we don't look we don't look for
stuff that's terrible in that Mystery
Science Theater way we look for stuff
that's terrible and the like you really
thought that your casual racism was okay
for television yes right or you really
thought that like your heavy-handed
message was like justified all the other
stuff that you need to watch Maude
recently no we don't have cable so you
get me TV and this TV yeah mods on a lot
and I love Bea Arthur with the power of
the Sun yeah but Maude stop hitting me
stop hitting me bond with your feminism
yeah and the justice and the social
justice and that and I was like because
parts of it there are at least five
great lines in every 22 minute episode
and there are at least three times when
you want to crawl through the screen and
kill everybody with a pillow boy that
would be a really long and uncomfortable
death unless they were in their bed you
just suffocated them I was actually
think you just like you know bags of gas
with a pillow I'm you know what I love
on the me TV is the Svengoolie show is
on Saturday nights what's that
spin Ghoulies a horror host like Elvira
yeah yes so his his shtick is he like
kind of comes out of a coffin and like
does all this ridiculous stuff and then
before and after they throw to the movie
he like says things that engage with
clips from the movie like maybe bits of
dialogue or whatever and there's like
like really low five blue screen effects
of like putting him into movies and
stuff and right it's delightfully
charming and and it's it's just those I
really you know I the Saturday matinee
movies on on local television when local
television still existed right I loved
them I really really really loved them
and then as I was coming of age in in in
college Mystery Science Theater was such
a man
massive profound influence on
hard-working me we were roommates in
college so where are you yeah so so we
were we were so massively shaped by our
two biggest influences were probably ren
and stimpy and Mystery Science Theater
3000 right I'd I knew all those guys
from stand-up in Minneapolis yeah
Science Theater 3000 over the years I've
been very fortunate to come to know
trace and Kevin and Bill Corbin and Joel
a little bit but mostly Kevin and and
and Bill and I will never grow tired of
hearing Kevin occasionally do the Tom
servo boys never get tired right I uh
I'm closer with Josh and marriage appeal
yeah so those are but it's but I'm
collecting them all I had out yeah yeah
and all that's left actually is trace
from the original yeah to have them to
collect them all in the dark forest
feel free yeah so tabletop games let's
just a plug in cuz we're at an hour okay
this is thank you so much for being on
the show but it's a real pleasure I hope
that my lying beard thing is interest
we're looking for that's what we're
looking for a dark forest farm you can't
you can't there's no way there's not
enough minutia to really so yeah the but
I'll get you back on to talk about these
other directives but the bag is right
okay let me ask you we have to two
things about beer yeah if anyone is
actually interested right and as and as
and as you know they're your curiosity
to speak and you kind of want to check
it out there's two books there's lots
and lots and lots of books up there's
only two books that you need okay
there's a book called the complete joy
of home brewing by an author named
Charlie Papazian and they're Armenian
and they're and there's and there's a
book called how to brew by a guy named
John Palmer those are the only two books
you will ever need there's others and
they're all great but those are the only
two that are like yeah those are
essentially you have to have them okay
you can go almost most towns have a home
brew supply okay
I really recommend going to a home brew
supply because I should always support
local businesses if there's a local
brick-and-mortar one and and also it's
just it's a cool community hub right
you'll meet somebody who can help you
yeah and brewers by and large I mean I'm
sure there's dick wagons out there I
never met one okay everyone I've met
who's a brewer and I've met lots of them
are so friendly and willing to help we
love it we're super passionate about our
hobby yeah and there was someone who was
awesome to me when I was starting and if
I have an opportunity to be that to
someone else I always take it and I
think a lot of home brewers have that
attitude that's local homebrew supply
but online you've got Northern Brewer
Austin homebrew supply Brooklyn the
Brooklyn Borough shop I think it's
called a beer shop they're all Midwest
supplies is also really good there's
just tons of places you can go and and
the communities that you can look at are
really really friendly okay and it's
really fun Brooklyn Bruce shop has a
fantastic saying if you can make oatmeal
you can make a beer and it is a hundred
percent correct okay cool so everybody
follow will on Twitter go to wil wheat
don't follow me on twitter and orest
don't follow will on twitter that's the
worst
yeah so it's a event but it's will W if
you were to not want to follow him you
to avoid him on Twitter you should avoid
at will W that's it and there's Wil
Wheaton dotnet to have all links to all
your different podcasts and tabletop
gaming oh yeah yeah there's there's a
menu there somewhere that has that has
links to all of the various things that
I do and on pretty much every social
network I am in descending order either
will W it's Wil Wheaton or Wil Wheaton
there you go find him I'm sure you'll
see him around I think you so much for
doing thanks for having me Jackie this
was really fun and you know the rules
folks take care of each other out there
like my hat my hat my hat they're
dancing around my hat hat my hat my hat
well what do you think of that if it
looks like a Mexican hat that sounds
like it's most likely a Mexican hat so
take off your head and let's dance
why don't we just call that as the end
of the show